you criticize China you criticize Nike
you're not going to play basketball
every game you pissed off the Turkish
people but this wasn't enough right
because you then had to piss off the
Chinese Communist party as well tell us
about that and the more I study the more
I realized
wow
this is just crazy and no one have a
courage to talk about this issue so I
was like from now on I'm gonna talk
about everything theaters because I was
in the hypocrisy you know
so BLM and everything was for them it
was just PR
I asked them one simple question I was
like put yourself in their shoes if
you're a mother if your sister if your
daughter wasn't concentration camps
getting tortured and rape every day
would you still pick money and business
over your morals values and prisons they
usually turn around and leave them every
organization see or companies has been
bought
by someone
bad author
hello and welcome to trigonometry on the
road from the USA I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constantine kitchen and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with Fascinating People our brilliant
guest today is a former NBA star and now
activist
Ennis formerly Canton Alfred and welcome
to trigonometry thank you for having me
um listen man thank you so much for
coming your fasting you just got off a
plane so we we we we're grateful for
your time
um I was actually a big fan of yours
when you were playing in the NBA but a
lot of our audience who are not that
into sport may not know who you are so
tell us your story how how what's your
journey through life are you you're born
in Turkey I actually born in Switzerland
you're born in Switzerland right I won't
say anything else you tell us yeah so my
father is a scientist and he was doing
his master in Switzerland and that's
where I'm born and uh you know I
literally stayed up for maybe nine
months I wanted to I wish I stayed along
because I could just speak another
language but came to Syria key I grew up
in east side of a city called one I
don't know if you guys ever heard that
before or not it's a beautiful beautiful
Town beautiful city
um you know my whole life actually when
I was growing up I wanted to be a soccer
player because I mean it's Europe it's
the number one sport in my country so I
was like you know what let me just be a
soccer player but I was too tall too
slow for it you know so they would just
keep making me a goalie so I was like
you know what I'm just gonna I'm done
I'm done with the support and a lot of
my friends were like you know you're
like the tallest man in a school why
don't you just stop playing basketball
and actually my family did not want me
to play basketball they were all about
education I remember you know my I give
a promise to my dad I was like it was
like listen son I want you to be a good
student before being a good basketball
player so I want you to focus on uh
school first because it's not guaranteed
that you're gonna make it you know there
are millions of kids out there trying to
make it to MBA so it's not a promise
that you're gonna make it so focus on uh
basketball uh and bus game time school
but so that was the biggest reason I
came to America as a teenager so I could
just go to school and play basketball
the same time and so you ended up you
ended up coming here
um and tell us like what what how did
were you just naturally talented or did
you have to work your butt off to get in
the NBA both but you have to I mean yeah
I want to well in
so I'm sure you guys don't forget about
you yes yes it was one of the biggest
you know the club team in Turkey so I
was playing for them but when I was 16 I
was literally playing against you know
those guys who are like 30 35s you know
so in Turkey there's no schools you know
you only go to Club teams and you focus
on you know just uh making your team uh
better it doesn't matter you're 16
you're 18 you're 20 if you're good
enough then you can play with guys who
are 30 35 you know so that made me a
tougher player uh but coming here
the high in high school I was literally
going against kids who are like you know
and we were just we're kids yeah
literally kids yeah so playing against
this girl bands don't play against kids
I was like you know what this is just
too easy
so in high school I was one of the best
players in a nation and then I got
um you know I committed and signed with
University of Kentucky I believe the
best basketball program in uh in in the
nation I went there for one year then I
got drafted by Utah Jazz wow so he got
drafted by the Utah Jazz and what was it
like playing NBA
you know so my first regular season game
was uh against Lakers against Kobe
Bryant at Star Plus oh so that's awesome
man so I grew up as a Lakers fan yeah
right so playing against Kobe for the
first time ever yeah foreign 20
000 people
I was like I remember coach called my
name I'm sitting on the bench and I'm
walking right to the uh in the game I'm
like my knees are shaking
I'm getting thirsty my knees are shaking
I'm like what's going on
um one of my teammate Mr shot I got the
offensive rebound and I was about to
finish they found me yeah so I'm in a
free throw line and I see Paul Gasol I
see
um
um Andrew Bynum and I said Kobe was
reading for me to shoot a free throw oh
wow this is like three legendary exactly
yeah so there are 20 000 people are
booming and I was like oh my God so I
like I spin the ball I'm taking couple
uh dribbles I'm gonna shoot
my hair I can feel I can see that my
hands are shaking
I took a shot I missed and everybody was
like Yay whatever and I'm like oh my
gosh I don't know if I can do this so
the second shot I'm like okay
I took the shot I made it I was like
this is gonna be my life from now so I
better get used to it yeah so at that
moment I'm like just start playing and
that game we
end up losing by 30 points Kobe ended up
scoring 40 points and it was a very
tough game for us so it was like a it
was my welcome back to the leaf moment
yeah welcome back welcome to the league
moment so so
um you know at that after that I was
just like you know just practice hard
and try to do my best to just be be one
of those uh players and and it's what
does it take to become a professional
athlete but more specifically an NBA
athlete do you need a special mindset
you know everybody obviously talking
about the mindset and the practice I I
feel like to all the kids actually are
asking me this if you want to become a
basketball player you have to live like
an NBA player because not only
practicing two three it's just not
enough
you have to eat well sleep well go to
sleep early be disciplined you have to
be dedicated and I think the mental
toughness is the most important part and
if you're playing basketball especially
in VA because now with all the social
media and Twitter and Instagram I mean
you miss one important shot
like the whole
City whole state of just like is
destroying you I remember in some of the
playoff games right I mean you cannot
play good every game so I remember in
some of the playoff games I mean it if I
have a bad game I was like
didn't want to even go out to a
restaurant or a mall or to walk around I
was just like very worried about what
the fans will say you know yeah so to me
it was always like okay I gotta have a
good game or they just gonna just
destroy him in the media the fans are
gonna say the craziest things and all my
friends and family and everyone gonna
read it so it was like I was like
it was just taking a lot of
it was just taking a lot out of me it
sounds like a lot of pressure man oh my
God yeah a lot of pressure because if
there was no media if there was no this
like
Sports writers whatever then like you're
good but their job is literally to just
wait for you to make a mistake so they
can put that mistake everywhere in the
world and obviously once the sports
writer writes anything about it then the
national media takes it and everyone
talks about it that's why it's like it's
so
20 is I always say like 20 of it is just
physical and 80 mental because physical
part you can literally just go going to
the gym and work out for two hours and
lift and after the practice you can get
some extra shots and you're good you
know
so the physical part is easy but the
mental part is the toughest part and how
did you deal with that because it's
something that a lot of people we talk
to who are not in Sports World you know
you you become a public commentator you
write a book or whatever and you find
yourself in a position where people have
an opinion about you that you can't
control right you know it's it was just
so weird because like you cannot have
any bad days because those fans don't
know what you're going through you might
have a family problem you might you
maybe maybe you broke up with your
girlfriend or you're having a problem at
home uh maybe you're getting divorced or
maybe you're about to have a kid so you
not every day your mind is with
basketball
but the fans see that and they're like
we are paying thousands of dollars to
watch you play so we're like it was like
a circus you know it was literally like
a circus and we cannot have any bad days
um
so how you come
I think the one thing that we always did
was just every
after game we're just sitting down in a
locker room and if someone had a bad day
if someone missed like a very important
shot if uh
if someone doesn't feel like themselves
we're sitting down in a locker room and
and say okay we are family we whatever
is whatever is happening let's talk in a
locker room and whatever happens in a
locker room stays in a locker room you
know maybe we're gonna fight maybe we
were gonna talk maybe we were going to
discuss this that but it's not gonna
come out of this Locker
um so that made all of us feel so much
better I'm like okay like you know some
people I missed the game-winning shot
the whole city might hate me you know no
uh the whole media is gonna destroy me
tomorrow morning but at least I have my
teammates back yeah you know and we're
we always have this strategy if one of
this media that will come after us we're
going to protect each other yeah you
know because media media laws drama so
they're gonna be like well this player
didn't pass you the ball you could have
just dumped the ball are you mad at him
and if you say anything
that my and inside you are Madison of
course
we could have win the game yeah but if
you cannot even if you like you like
maybe like even if you roll your eyes
yes I promise you they take a screenshot
of that right and the next day oh Ennis
doesn't like his teammates yeah so
that's why athletes when they get asked
questions by the media it's always the
same you know oh I love my teammates I
we just need to work hard and we'll get
the next one but that's not what we
talking about obviously the locker room
you're like dude if I was open why
didn't you pass me the ball right or
like what's going on do we have a
problem yeah so we were trying to solve
every problem in a locker room and when
we got out of this locker room we're all
good yeah there's a there's the the most
famous and the best rugby union team in
the world in New Zealand All Blacks and
they have a policy uh called the no
[__] policy that's literally the
name of it and what they say is it
doesn't matter how talented you are it
doesn't matter how good a rugby player
you are if you are a [__] you're not
going to play for the All Blacks I love
it if you're actually I had a teammate
Stephen Adams so you know Steven Adams
Stephen Adams from New Zealand yeah
great player one of the one of the uh
games I had a really good game and he
said I mean he's going to bring me a
gift so the next game you brought me
this
um all black uh Jersey yeah I can't
remember who he was but uh I was like oh
cool I posted it and so many people were
just retweeting it and liking it and
said we didn't know you're a fan
whatever but uh but no I had a I had a
teammate like that yeah Stephen Adams
and we've talked about you know the
pressure but what's probably even more
difficult and assist how do you deal
with success how do you deal from going
from a regular background to all of a
sudden being a young kid who is
surrounded by wealth adulation Fame
women I mean if that had happened to me
when I was 20 I'd be in rehab 19 19.
even worse to your teenager I mean
um so that's why NBA had this like
programs it calls like rookie transition
program you know so um
whenever you enter the league you go to
these programs and the older or retired
players comes and gives you their
experience that what happened throughout
their career and some of the things that
you hear is just unbelievable because
think about this you're 19 years old
you're just getting drafted the whole
world is talking about you they're
giving you millions of dollars and
everywhere you go you don't have to pay
for anything you eat free food you shop
free you do everything for free you know
and you literally become a huge
celebrity and now with all the social
media and everything you have a huge
influence and you can Inspire so many
people but sometimes like players don't
know what to do with all this Fame all
this money you know so that's why they
they go to clubs and they go to bars and
they find 10 20 girlfriends and it just
boom did you do any of that no because I
had a really good team around me really
good team around me and they always
protected me in you know because I mean
Coming to America coming to America my
family raised me really well and they
were like you know I'm obviously because
of my faith because I'm a Muslim I'm not
allowed to drink I'm not allowed to
really go out I'm not allowed to do
certain things that my teams my
teammates were doing it you know so that
really protected me but other than that
I'm you know I had a I think average NBA
players career is four years wow yeah
because they come into the league boom
clubs girls drinks this and that and
they're gone
you know yeah so
it was your faith that kept you on the
straight and narrow but I guess the
question is as well it's just
there must have been a part of you that
was tempted there must have been a part
of you where you just thought to
yourself
as you know you know look we're all men
we're all human there must have been a
couple of ladies when you're like
I've worked really hard this week it is
it was it is so crazy because everywhere
we go they were waiting for us we go to
hotel they're waiting at the lobby we go
to a game they're waiting we go to a
restaurant we go to mall they know our
schedule obviously the schedule was out
before the season so every
um
City we go
for somehow they already know the hotel
we're staying so it's like you're going
back you go down the lobby and there are
like
this was before Instagram right once the
Instagram came so they already know our
schedule you know so before we go to the
cities they were already having us I
said hey you know you're coming to our
city let's hang out
and it was literally like a menu you
just literally just scroll it down okay
I did not do this I'm just saying like
yeah of course people who did it it was
like a minute you just go down you're
like I want a blunt today I want a
brunette today I want this I want that
you could literally just pick or one two
maybe more you know so uh that's why a
lot of the players were just losing
focus because of all that yeah you know
they thought that this is going to last
forever
you know but
they were just going out and partying
all night and coming to the game the
next day they can't even walk because
they're angry from last night you know I
had a lot of teammates I'm like we had a
game so we usually go to the city the
night before and then in the morning we
have practice and then at time we play
basketball we play the game I have a lot
of teammates even in the morning
before the practice they were like they
could hardly walk so I'm like how are
you gonna go out there and play
basketball compete against these guys
like Kobe LeBron or Kevin Garnett Dirk
Nowitzki Paul Gasol and they're like
well I'll be fine I'll take a nap
he would end up getting hurt because his
body was just not ready for that for 11.
and also it makes it more challenging
particularly if you come like a lot of
these guys from very poor backgrounds
where you have nothing and then it's not
like you go into business and gradually
you build yourself up and you're
starting to make it's zero to a hundred
miles an hour that's why you know like
you ask so many people a lot of the NBA
players goes broke right after the
career because you know when you come
from like you know poor families and
your first contract is like 20 million
dollar what do you want to do you want
to show off right so you want to buy
your friend a car you want to buy your
other friend a house you want to buy
another friend a car and these are like
really expensive cars and homes so you
really want to you you're really trying
to take care of your whole street or
your whole neighborhood you know and you
go out there and buy this like a hundred
thousand dollars or juries or watches
and stuff which you don't even need you
know so they always think that okay
money is going to come
forever but no the only when you get
hurt you're done you know if you don't
take care of yourself
if you have like an injury prawn then
the players are the teams are not going
to sign you
what was the big thing that you bought
with my with my first
[Music]
um
with my first Contact I literally took
my
teammates or Pizza Hut
it's a Pizza Hut and we had a we had a
blast we had so much fun and he was like
all you can eat too so you were just
like killing it yeah you know but I'm
trying to think I really didn't buy
anything like house car nothing what
nothing really nothing I'm as you see
I'm a very simple very simple person I
mean I was like the one thing I've
always done I was just donating a lot of
money to some of the families out there
especially in Turkey
um because I'm sure you guys know this
situation over there yeah well we'll
talk about it we'll talk about it but um
but other than that I didn't really buy
anything crazy
hey Constantine do you like being
healthy of course in my country we judge
Men's Health by his ability to wrestle
bear turns out in London Russell bear
has very different meaning
[Applause]
we will speak no more of this the secret
will be buried with my ancestors well if
you want to stay healthy and not feel
like you need to be buried with
Constantine's ancestors then you need to
try ag1 ag1 is simple and easy way to
get all nutrients you need each serving
contains 75 high quality vitamins
minerals and Whole Food sourced
ingredients one scoop and you feel like
real men we use it on our America Tour
where we were constantly on the Move
living out of a bag and working every
day ag1 meant we felt great look great
and we avoided getting sick one scoop a
day meant we knew we had all the
vitamins and minerals needed for the day
we had hugely successful trip it is very
economical and I felt strong enough to
wrestle American bird which we all know
is grotesly weak compared to Great
Russian word if you're looking for a
simpler and cost effective supplement
routine ag1 is giving you a free one
year is supply of vitamin D and five
travel packs with your first purchase go
to athleticgreens.com
trigonometry that athleticrings.com
trigonometry check it out and become
real men like me
one of the questions that's always
interested me about when you talk to
Elite athletes is obviously everybody
who plays the NBA is absolutely
exceptional as an athlete but there is
this kind of little strata of the people
at the top and it doesn't matter whether
it's football like Lionel Messi
Cristiano Ronaldo or it's people like
Kobe Bryant
that little sliver of people at the top
won't makes them so special that even as
professional athletes are Head and
Shoulders above every single other
person what makes him so special I
believe is I mean
we're all athletes we know how to train
our body you know we know what to do
when we go in the gym when we work out
we know our weaknesses we know our
strengths
um you know we know how to eat well
sleep well and we have all the resources
I think the mindset you know I I had so
many teammates like you know like Damian
Lillard Russell Westbrook Kevin Durant
Jason Tatum these player were the one
that always like coming to the gym first
and leaving last and um
I think what makes him so special is you
know they were not only just so amazing
individually but they make themselves
better and they make everybody else
better around them that's what make him
really special and I think being a good
leader is really important in this
league you know you can you can average
20 25 points but if you're not winning
any games if you're not helping your
teammates if you're not affecting the
game you know that's just just nothing
they're just like an empty empty stats
yeah we call it empty stats you know but
if you're instead of 25 you scoring 20
points but you're making your teammates
score 10 15 points and now they're happy
they want to play they want to win games
you know so that's what
separates from great players and good
players and you play a position where
people giving you the ball is important
like you need people the little guys to
give you the assist so that's coming
from that well before we move on to to
the more the your activism and other
things best player you ever play with
oh that's a tough one I might go with
Russell Westbrook really yeah I'm God I
gotta pick him over
because when I play with him I mean the
the season that I play with him
um he ever tripled double he got the MVP
and he was the best player in the league
you know and now right now people give
him so much
uh people right now I just really like
talk badly about him because of his
character whatever but I think he was
one of the best team that I had that's
so interesting can I push back just as a
casual basketball fan because I always
think when I look at Russell Westbrook
is that individually he's a great player
but I always thought the reason he's not
won anything is that his style it's not
about his temperament or personality his
style is not necessarily always making
the team better but you say the opposite
I'm totally saying the opposite because
he actually I mean he and Russell please
don't hurt me I'm a lot smaller to
understand Russell you have to play with
Russell right you know that's when you
know how good of a teammate is on and
off the court that's how you know how
good of a leader he is and how good of a
basketball player he is you know so a
lot of people give him
um
a lot of bad stuff so why do you think
he hasn't been able to win the chips I
mean there are a lot of great players
out there that did not win any
Championship like Carl Malone
uh Chuck
um trying to think who else uh there are
I mean many other players that they now
win a championship you know so uh
so yeah all right um and who's the best
player that you played against who was
the guy that when you saw you were just
going to think yeah oh not this not not
him again please
Kobe Bryant really you came in the
league one oh 2011.
so he was already maybe past his prime a
little bit but I mean he was still
chilling oh yeah he was killer obviously
yeah but um I might say you know up I
mean Kevin Uh Kevin Durant I played
against Stephen Curry I played against
and third I played against but I'm
trying to think I think I'll say Kobe
what what was so special about him what
made him so different
just
I think his mentality you know everyone
talks about the mama mentality but I
think his mentality was this just on a
different level you know he was like I
said again it was always first one in
the gym and he was just that he hates
losing some people some players love
winning yeah he hate losing there's a
big difference when I get drafted one of
the scholars asked me do you love
winning or you hate losing I was like I
hate losing I was like but you know but
uh that's the right mentality if you
want to be super successful yeah so but
he did not his Focus was just on a
different level a very professional
unbelievable guy and you also it's I I
see it in sport a lot particularly
soccer there are some players Cristiano
Ronaldo is the ultimate example of this
exactly who have a Killer Instinct he's
a killer no we so when I was playing
with Oklahoma City Thunder we actually
went to Real Madrid and we watched him
play and we actually get to meet him I
got to Madam right after the game
and you know always you always see him
on social media or TV have his like
ripped and stuff yeah I promise we have
a picture he was like not even quarter
wall size I'm like this is
the guy that is on TV just all ripped
and stuff yeah it was just like this is
like very skinny oh compared to us he
was very very small yeah well basketball
players carry a lot more muscles because
you don't run as much well Ennis listen
one of the things I really enjoyed so
far in our conversation is when you talk
about basketball you light up it's
something I can tell it's something you
enjoy you enjoyed right
and yet as we sit here you're not an NBA
player yeah and you don't even have the
same name that you had right because you
made some changes and you spoke up about
things that you cared about and you've
paid the price
right tell us about that well I mean my
actually my activism started when I was
a kid so in Turkey I'm not sure how much
you guys know the Turkish politics
whatever so if you're if you're in
Turkey if you're a politician you do if
you want to be elected again you do two
things you attack America and you attack
Israel the just because of the base is
so uneducated right they're like wow
look at our leader he's standing strong
against America he's standing tall
against Israel so a lot more let's vote
for
so that was the situation when I was
growing up so on TV newspaper there was
just propaganda all day
um
I am not I was nine years old I went
downstairs to play with my friends and I
uh
I remember my friends they're not even
teenagers my little friends were burning
Flags they were burning American flags
they were burning Israeli flags and I uh
I asked them could you guys what are you
doing they said well that's what we've
seen on TV they're evil they're bad
they're terrible so they gave me a flag
to burn it
I took the flag I took the lighter I'm
looking at it I'm like this is not right
right way to do it so I threw it down I
ran upstairs to my mom
I was like Mom
my friends are telling me to hate
America they're telling me to hate
Israel they tell them they hate Jewish
people hate Christians hate Americans
what do I do
my mom said
I'm not going to tell you what to do but
do not hate anyone before you meet them
and I'm nine years old so that day I
give a promise I'm not gonna hate anyone
um so when I was 17 years old right my
dad was seeing the environment that I
was growing up in they're like this is
just too toxic get out of here so
they wanted me to play basketball and
get my education the same time so they
said okay it's time for the good America
so I I remember coming here for the
first time my plane was about to land
I'm so excited by saying that I'm so
nervous because I just don't know what
to expect because the last 17 years the
environment I live in was just very
toxic because you ask if you have any
friends in Middle East you ask him you
know in some of the schools in some of
the classes in Middle East they have
Flags they have American flags and they
have Israeli flags and if you are a
student if you're a little kid if you
don't step on those flags you're not
allowed to attend the class wow think
about it and I am growing up in an
environment like that
so I'm coming to I came to America for
the first time I'm so like
shocked I'm just looking around and
trying to like get to know people and
stuff but I remember my teammates trying
to had a conversation for with me with
me for the first time I left locker room
and I just didn't know what they were
trying to do and they were so nice they
were like hey let's take you to a mosque
let's uh take you to go get some halal
food and stuff I was like what are they
trying to do I remember going to my
first Shabbat dinner
it was very interesting because I didn't
know she was Jewish or I don't think I
will ever even be
friends with her in the beginning
um
so then I remember the promise that I
gave to my mom I was like okay I'm
coming before I went to her house
to have a Shabbat dinner with her family
I called my Turkish friend who lives in
America I was like if you don't hear
from me for the next two hours call the
police
because I just don't know what to expect
anyway it's a good chance I went there
it was an amazing amazing dinner I mean
because I don't know I don't know how
much you guys know but like they're so
close to our religion our culture the
food is almost like the same so it was
unbelievable experience when I when I
was going back to my
my hotel I started to tear up because I
was thinking there are millions of kids
in the Middle East right now is grown up
anti-semitic anti-west anti-American
anti uh Christian just because of those
hate speeches coming from these
politicians so I was like we gotta
change it you know and then after that I
promised myself I was like whatever it
takes I'm gonna stand for what's right
and how did that then manifest in your
NBA career because when I was watching
the NBA as I do you know you you were a
great player you played for a number of
teams yeah I saw you playing New York
and Oklahoma and and you know a bunch of
Portland as well you mentioned Damian
Lillard but I never really heard
anything at the time and that's maybe
because I wasn't paying enough attention
but it seemed like there was a
particular couple of moments maybe that
really changed the trajectory of your
life and your career so there was a
corruption Scandal happened in Turkey
back in 2013.
and that was the first time I said
something about it because president
erdogan and his family members were
involved in it and uh
so after the conference Scandal I said
something I literally put it like a very
simple tweet out there
because of the MBA platform it became a
conversation in the United States and uh
in Turkey
we're in New York man yeah so I was like
even one simple tip it can affect This
Much from now and I'm gonna start pay
attention about what's going in my
country more and more so I started to
study I remember my teammates were going
out to parties clubs and whatever and I
was going back to my house I was
studying about what's going on between
Italy yeah what's going on the Middle
East what's going on between America and
turkey and stuff so the more I study the
more I started to talk about these
problems and obviously every time I told
you I was becoming a conversation
and Turkish government hated that I mean
first my dad was a scientist he got
fired from his job my sister went to
medical school for six years and she
still cannot find a job my little
brother was playing basketball he wanted
to be like his big brother to play an
NBA but he was getting kicked out in
every team because the same last name so
they were getting affected so much they
had to put a statement out there and
said we are disowned in NS actually the
letter is still out there on the
internet you guys can't read it if you
want
after that letter I remember going to a
practice it was definitely one of the
toughest day of my life right so then
Turkish government didn't believe that
they sent police to my house in turkey
and they raided the whole house and they
took every electronics away phones
computers laptops iPads because they
wanted to see if I am still in contact
with my family or not so after the radar
they couldn't find no evidence but they
still took my dad in jail for a while
but we put so much pressure from here
for the politicians and media with some
of the celebrities to Turkey they had to
let him go and then you know they revoke
my passport they put my name on
interpolis they put a bounty on my head
and you know they
send that to us every week now and stuff
I have 12 arrests warning for me right
now in less than nine years so just for
speaking just you know the crazy thing
is whenever I like had to have a
conversation with some of them whenever
I give an interview I always say look at
my every interview that I have given so
far look at every all pads look at
everything I have write or tweet so far
I never talk about politics
I keep it pure human rights and I talk
about political prisoners and if that
makes me a terrorist
okay I'll take it I guess you know what
I mean so uh so the reason I did not
want to talk about politics is because
human rights is about politics so I was
like you know what I don't care about
the politics side of it I just want to
help people so I was like it's pure
human rights and and it's what made you
keep going because there's a lot of
people who would see what was being the
pain that was being inflicted on their
family and would think look family first
right and I'm just going to step back
and I have a lot of I have a lot of
empathy for that point of view you know
the family always first 100 but you know
people knows my situation and my family
situation because I have to start
playing NBA but there are thousands of
families author in jail uh their
situations way worse than mine I mean I
I was looking at the numbers just
recently right now there are 17 000
innocent women are in the jail waiting
for help and this woman have did not
commit no crime you know these are just
Housewives lawyers doctors teachers
whatever and they work in a places which
is or they work in a media Outlet which
is said something against the regime in
Turkey
um and a lot of the reports out there
like Amnesty International human rights
watching or Foundation saying that these
women are getting tortured and raped you
know so I'm like I had to make a
decision I'm like you know
it obviously it's important to go about
be able to go back to my country see my
family hang out with my brothers and
sister and stuff
but here there are thousands of people
are suffering and did you do you feel a
particular sense of Duty because you
have a big audience because you have a
platform I think so I think you know
this platform is given me by God so I
was like you know what this is just
God's work because I'm not making I'm
actually losing money I'm actually
losing endorsement deals by talking
about these issues
um you know it's not like this it's not
like this is making me more famous this
is getting me better contract this is
making me join better teams this is
literally like taking a lot of out of me
but I it's still important for me and I
imagine your agent
was going well he wasn't obvious he
wasn't happy because once you talk about
this problems many of the teams
especially the owners are like hmm I
mean this is a huge
um deal this guy literally they consider
him as international criminal they put a
bounty on his head
um so it's a big distraction
for our team you know because
it was whenever I joined a team the
whole year was not about basketball that
whole year was about the whole
International media was talking about
what's going on in my life either a
bounty either me meeting with the world
leaders or either me going to talking
about some of the problems that are
happening in the world
um so the the
Focus was shifting away from basketball
and no one
couldn't say anything like why are you
doing it because like I said again it
was pure human rights or no one really
could have challenged me so
um
so for the for the coaches or for the
owners it was a big distraction and and
is did anybody
speak honest if you shut your mouth
this will mean that you get a better
deal there's a chance that you could go
to a better Club there's a chance that
you could have a far better career right
not when the topic was searched but when
the when the topic was China yes well
this is what I was gonna say because you
you pissed off the Turkish business but
this wasn't enough right because you
then had to piss off the Chinese
Communist party as well tell us about
that oh just before we do that there's
one thing that I want to say because I
see Meza Ozil who is a huge Turkish
footballer and he has appeared in
photographs so and he's supporting
German Football German Turkish
footballer and with erdogan
so I did respect them
till he took a picture with erdogan you
know it's not like
so he he did talk about the origi was
literally talking about some of the
important things that are happening in
our world and stuff so I was like wow
this is very amazing this is very
interesting and a soccer player going
out there and talking about something
bigger than soccer but this is beautiful
till I saw that he's endorsing erdogan
then he lost me and not he did not only
lose me he lost
millions of people around the world now
whenever I go and have a conversation
with one of the Turkish people per
person whatever they said well I mean he
will he was a good player but you know
he has he's affiliated with yeah erdogan
so you talk about turkey you have all
this trouble
but that's not enough for you
so this is how how it all started
so the for the last 10 years I focused
on Turkey the reason obviously my plate
was full because my family I haven't
been able to see my family almost 10
years now a lot of my friends and
neighbors and whatever in Turkey stuck
in jails and stuff so just last summer
I am doing a basketball camp in New York
so after that we had an amazing
basketball here in Camp with the kids
um after the basketball camp all the
kids just lined up for me and they were
just getting pictures and taking uh you
know getting autographs one by one so I
remember so I took a picture with this
kid and his parents called me out front
of everybody
the media was there my friends
um some of my you know other you know
athlete friends were there and little
kids were there he said how can you call
yourself a human right activist when
your Muslim brothers and sisters are
getting tortured and raped every day in
concentration camp in China
and I'm still smiling for the camera so
I took a picture with this kid I turned
around I was like I promise I'm gonna
get back to you
so that day I cancel everything I went
back to my hotel I started the study
about what's going on over there in
China
and the more I study the more I realized
wow
this is just crazy and no one had the
courage to talk about decision
you see uyghurs and the more you study
you see like Tibetans Hong kongers
Taiwanese people Mongolians falun gongs
they are all under heavy persecution by
Chinese governments
it's almost like
well I gotta talk about it but on
internet you can find all kind of news
you don't know which one to trust so bad
it could be a fake news it could be real
news so I call my manager I was like I
need you to find me a concentration camp
Survivor obviously he was very shocking
that what are you talking about he said
well just find me one so he did find me
when he was a lady
so we sit down
had a conversation I had an amazing
one-hour conversation with her you know
um I wanted to just learn the story from
you know firsthand so she was telling me
about all the torture methods all the
gang raping all the you know Force
sterilization abortion and organ
harvesting and surveillance cameras
and I was like the more she talked the
more I was like share with myself I was
like I cannot believe that God gave me
this huge platform and I only focused on
one dictatorship so I was like from now
on I'm gonna talk about every
dictatorship
so
I ended our conversation I asked her I
was like how can I help she said I don't
need your help I'm good I was like so
why do we have this one-hour
conversation for no reason like why did
you even come here she said I live in
America I live a good life here I can do
whatever I want I can say whatever I can
eat whatever I want but help those
people help those two three million
legals are in concentration camp in
China because they are getting tortured
and rape every day so at that moment I'm
like I don't care what kind of contract
or endorsement deal or anything you can
offer me I'm just gonna go out there and
just expose the whole system that's how
it all started and we know that the NBA
has the Chinese market is bigger than
the American Market exactly so this
didn't go down well
so like I said again I wanted to do it I
wanted to do it in a very unique way so
later on if someone comes and say why
are you doing this
I'm like this is human rights so you
don't you're telling me that you don't
care about human rights you know so I
want to do it in a very unique way
because I remember when I was a kid
whenever I watched an NBA game the first
thing I was watching was the shoes I
mean everyone loves shoes what color
they are what brand it is if they're
comfortable the next day I was telling
my dad please buy those shoes for me you
know
so I had this
idea I was like let's reach out to these
artists around the world which
have been oppressed by their governments
because they are the one that knows the
story more than anyone
and um
and we're like let's tell them to put
all the struggles all this you know
emotion all the stories on the shoes and
we're going to go out there and play
basketball and these shoes are non-slim
neighbor I mean many of the shows out
there in the world right now
unfortunately they have sweatshops on
the slave Labyrinth anyway so
we created the shoes
uh our for my first topic was Tibet free
Tibet you know it's not a political it's
literally a human rights issue
so I put the shoes on 50 bad shoes I
went out there and played basketball it
was right
I by my our first game I was playing for
the Celtics our first game against New
York Knicks it was the opening night for
the the New York and it was just the
whole world was watching that game it's
the biggest rivalry so I put the shoes
on I'm warming up and a minute before
the game two gentlemen from the NBA
came to me and said take your shoes off
I was like excuse me
they're like well you know your shoes
has been getting so much attention
internationally you got to take him off
so
at that moment I was I was just getting
ready for my citizenship test in America
so I was I closed my eyes I'm like okay
we have 27 events in America my first
time I've been Fremont speech I told
them no even if I get fined I'm not
taking them off they said we are not
talking about fine we're talking about
getting bad
wish there was no rule against it
so that half I play zero minutes
zero I went back to my locker room I had
thousands of notifications in my phone I
clicked on the one that my manager sent
me he said every Celtics game is banned
in China
it took them 24 minutes first first
quarter to the 12 minute second quarter
20 12 minutes 24 minutes depend every
Celtics game television
so I was like well that clearly shows
the censorship and the dictatorship over
there anyway so after that game I played
zero minutes we lost the game and uh
after the game there was just huge media
sound literally every media in the world
from the very random countries which I
never even heard of want to have an
interview
I told my manager to decline them all I
don't want to have no interview with
anyone I didn't want my teammates to
think I'm doing this for attention I was
like decline everything and he was like
are you sure it's like decline
everything
so after the game NBA called me
they're like well you know what you did
mbpa called me the player association
which I give thousands of dollars every
year to protect my rights against MBA
they said you cannot wear the shoes ever
again MB has been pressuring us I was
like am I breaking any rules they said
no they said well you cannot remember
again I was like if you're if I'm
breaking the rules tell me I won't wear
they pressure me so much I was like you
know what
fine I'm not going to wear free to
batches every game there's a promise I
said promise so we hang out the phone so
the next game I wore free regular shoes
so now that's what you call doubling
down so they call me after the game in
the second game they're like you're a
liar you lied to us we can never trust
you again I was like first of all relax
second I never lied to you I never said
I'm not gonna wear free legal shoes I
just said I'm just not going over 50
batches at that moment they got it they
were not going to be able to make me
apologize took my tweet down and say I
was not educated enough sorry whatever
so on uh after the second game one of my
teammates woke up to me and said you
know this is your last name NBA right if
you're criticize China you're criticized
Nike you're not gonna play basketball
every game have fun smile I hope you win
a championship but this is it for you
wow that was it and that and it was as
simple as that simple as that yeah and
but I mean you work so hard in this you
put you dedicated so much of your life
to get into the NBA you clearly love
basketball was there no part of you who
thought I mean of course I love
basketball but it's just the promise I
guess I'll say to give to my mom was
like Mom I promise I want to stand up
for what's right whatever it takes even
if it means sacrificing everything I
have you know
um
I mean people keep talking about
basketball
you're losing my career but
I talk about the problems were happening
in Turkey I pretty much lost my family I
haven't seen my mom and dad and my
sister over 10 years now you know
um
and also I just
when I know that on the other side of
the world people are losing their loved
ones losing their lives and losing their
homes I just couldn't play I just
couldn't go to sleep at night in peace
and what was your reaction of the
manager what was the reaction of the
coaches what was the reaction of your
teammates and they were just shocked
they're like everyone was shocked
because everybody knew that this is it
I'm not gonna play basketball and it's
not like I'm 35 years old it's not like
my I was 29 years old I could have
played another like six seven years so
if they
if I did if I did this whole thing
when I'm 35 36 they're like well you
know he was going to be down with
basketball anyway so he just did it to
Heaven next chapter in his life because
I could have literally played another
six seven years I'm healthy I love
basketball I love the NBA the basketball
side of it not the politic side of it
obviously but
um
this is just bigger than myself making
an MBA bigger than basketball and Ennis
I think anyone watching this or
listening to this will know that you're
coming from a a good place really from a
good place and you you're doing what you
believe and you're standing up for what
you believe but there are also people
who will say you know we see this with
kneeling in in for in relation to BLM in
the NBA and in uh in soccer we see this
with Colin Kaepernick uh Etc but there
are people who say you know
sport is Sport
and politics is politics
and you violated that separation so
there's a like I said from from the
beginning of our conversation there's a
difference between politics and human
rights I don't do politics I have never
in my life said even about turkey or
China let's vote for this guy let's vote
for this party I don't like I endorse
this person never in my life you know I
kept it pure him right so if they if
they are against what I'm saying them is
there against human rights
you know and because I don't and also
not only basketball players but athletes
has a huge platform they can literally
Inspire millions of kids out there now
with all the social apps phones
everything you know they could they're
just literally becoming an educator and
now you see all the kids are literally
just following
the daily routine that this
athletes have so it's in your hand to
just put the good things out there or
the bad things out there you know you
see all this some of the players were
putting out there with alcohol and girls
and clubs and all and expensive
jewelries and cars but same time you see
other athletes talking about
what's more important for our society
you know
so sorry I was going to say was there
not a part of you because you're
obviously a bright guy you have studied
about America and you looked at the way
the NBA have done have effectively
canceled and you think to yourself and
you thought to yourself well
this is my first amendment right I'm
gonna take you on was there not a part
of you was like right if we want to go
to battle let's go to battle I mean this
was the craziest thing because I was
just keep asking myself how can the
biggest dictatorship in the world can
control a hundred percent American-made
company and fire an American citizen
I will just keep asking this question to
myself and one of my friends said
study and you will see more so the more
I study the more I realized MBA is not
the only one you see Hollywood big tag
academias Wall Street
Farmland Congress local local
conferences they all run by one of the
dictatorships out there
like after the basketball after my
basketball career I was like you know
what basketball is over I am still an
athlete I'm still in a good shape let me
do something else about sports so I grew
up as a huge WWE Fan huge wrestling fan
so I was like well I was already in
conversation with some of my friends
over there and stuff
so I started to have conversations
people heard about it and stuff and uh
one day one of my friend called me from
WWE they said listen we know that you
like to talk about some of the you know
problems are out there happening in the
world but I gotta tell you something I
was like what happened
she said
talk about anything in the world you can
talk about anything in the world but if
you ever talk about Saudi Arabia you're
never going to wrestle
I was just like
what are you talking about
they said whatever China is for the MBA
is Saturday is WWE for Saudi Arabia
they said they make so much money from
Saudi Arabia every year which is girls
are not even allowed to wrestle there
uh if you say anything against it you're
not going to be able to wrestle I was
like well it's too late
you know so I see the more I study the
more I realize every organization see or
companies has been bought
by someone
bad author you know
um
I even call out you know all this the
war happening in Ukraine is obviously
it's horrible disgusting whatever but
you see all these like CEOs all these
organizations and companies are pulling
out of Russia
I was like we were just having this huge
conversation with many important people
I was like
if God forbid China that every child
invade Taiwan would you guys do the same
thing
no answer
and the reason is obviously because
China is a bigger and more powerful
model of course of course right and it's
and did you think that
I mean
you say it's not politics and I know
what you mean but these issues
unfortunately are political right people
politicize them and we saw with for
example BLM that NBA treated that very
differently
well the reason was they know that you
know during the NBA bubble I wasn't MBA
bubble I'm sure you guys know about the
NBA bubbles
so three years ago 2020 the covet hit
and be Alvis still wanted to make money
so they took all of us into a hotel in
Disney so we were in a hotel over 82
days and we just couldn't
you know meet with anyone from the
outside you know they were testing us
twice a day and uh
and it was all about social justice they
put the BLM logos on the floor they put
those phrases behind our Jersey which
was controlled by the MBA
uh it was all about social justice and
standing for what's right and I was like
you know what this is your freedom of
protest I got you if you want to do it
do it I'm not against it
uh but NBA knew that the things that
they stand up for in America is not
gonna
affect their business
they are gonna
shut you up
about anything if the things that you
talk about affects their money or
business
I was like because I was in the
hypocrisy you know
um so BLM and everything was for them it
was just PR
you know they were just trying to do PR
trying to get more clicks more eyeballs
more
um recognitions they're like wow look at
MBA is the first organization that goes
out there standing with African-American
community in America wow what an amazing
organization but then China happened
and I was like first couple of games I
was like seeing that
I was like where's my support where is
Adam Silver where is all this owners and
billionaires or teammates or coaches
where are they you know I was like you
know what I'm just gonna expose the
whole system
after I got released
China put the games back on television
after three weeks
and uh we found out we did the whole
investigation we found out 40 MBA owners
have
got tied up 10 billion in China
I was like well that clearly shows why
I'm out of the league yeah and did
teammates do they still talk to you or
are you kind of seen as a kind of pariah
figure good question so when I was with
when I was playing they were really
supportive silent support you know they
were very supportive they're like it was
the perfect moment because it was right
before the Beijing Olympics I was like
guys join me forget about the NBA I was
reaching out to NFL MLB NHL MLS all the
major leagues in America forget about
America was even reaching out to
Olympians I was like this is not a
political issue it's a human rights
issue so let's just join me we'll create
a movement we'll talk about the slavery
we'll talk about the swatches we talk
about the people over there dying
they're like listen we love you we
support you but we just cannot do it
aloud I was like why they said well we
have shoe deals endorsement deals we
want to get another contract
I asked them one simple question I was
like put yourself in their shoes if
you're a mother if your sister if your
daughter was on those concentration
camps getting tortured and raped every
day would you still pick money and
business over your morals values and
principles they usually turn around and
leave them wow so and do you think part
of this the reason you have this
attitude and this is the fact that you
have seen a totalitarian regime you know
what that means you understand that
whereas people who grow up in America
they don't understand what that means
they have no concept I remember one time
we're having conversation in a locker
room with my teammates and they were
like oh America is bad America is
horrible America is this and that I was
I stopped I was like guys season is
about to be over uh when the season over
let me buy your tickets it was a very
generous first class ticket it's like
when you buy your tickets and let's go
to this summer as dictatorships out
there
like Russia like China like Iran
Venezuela Cuba North Korea and I would
like to see if you guys can forget about
a tweet if you guys can't even criticize
or say something about about those
regimes you and your family members will
be in torture and raping jails forever
just because of they didn't grow up they
they grow up with so much freedom and
democracy is in this country they don't
know any better and then as this is such
a beautiful point you know as we talked
I'm from Russia France's mother is from
Venezuela it's one of the reasons we
talk about the things that we talk about
on the show and one of the things that
seems to me is the story of your story
and the NBA and how it handled BLM
versus how handle your Chinese and
Turkish protesters is is that it's okay
to beat up America
yeah America bad it's America's the
worst place ever and
you can't criticize anyone else we are
the worst people let's not look anywhere
else and you know that is correct and
also I was like I did I don't want to
say I will I wanted to educate my
teammates because they already knew they
already knew that their shoes has been
made by slave kids there's so much blood
and sweat and oppression behind those
items you know
um they knew a lot of the problems were
happening around the world they knew
some of the things that I even talk
about uh but then picking money in
business over their morals over what's
going on really broke my heart and now
when I got released
I played 11 years in MBA I had hundreds
of teammates Hanzo coaches so many
people from the foreign offices not the
one who impacts with me wow they said
hey man good luck with your next chapter
because they didn't want me to mention
their name whenever I given interview I
was like hey this guy supported me this
guy texting me which I would never do
without the without their permission
um because they know if I say hey this
guy supported me when I talked about
Hong kongers
um
he was going to get a lot of trouble
and why do you think they didn't is it
because they like the money is it
because they like their lifestyle is it
because they don't want to get in
trouble
I would say all but fear is the most
important one you know there are so many
um other examples out there like Richard
Kerr yeah I'm sure you know who that is
uh he was a he was an actor in Hollywood
and he talked about obviously Tibetans
and he was just gone after that you know
I think that they see this kind of
examples me getting released at the age
of like Prime of my time you know
um it's like a really big hit for him so
that's why I was like you know what this
whole system needs to be exposed and now
they've really lost 50 percent of the
country
you know and now whenever I have a
conversation with so many of you know
the sports fans they said well we love
NBA we love amazing but they don't stand
for what's right we don't believe that
they whenever they stand up for one of
the social justice issues that happened
in America did we know that it's not
going to hit their pocket or we know
that they're not genuine about it yeah
and it's you've been very generous with
your time so I don't want to hold you up
too much longer but are you happy you
happy you did this I'm very happy I have
zero regress a lot of people ask it that
is the one question that I get the most
do you have any regrets
um obviously I love basketball I love my
family forget about basketball I love my
family I haven't even been able to live
in
have a phone conversation with them for
years you know
um but at the end like I said again what
I'm doing is bigger than myself bigger
than basketball bigger than NBA because
while I was dribbling the ball in this
country on the other side of the world
other side of the ocean people will
people were suffering you know and
you can only understand that if you
lived it and I did live it you know many
of my my dad was in jail
many of my friends right now are still
in jail many of my neighbors
maybe ex teammates that played in Turkey
in jail just because they supported me
um
I'm happy I did it
but you know I mean I love basketball
and you can never goes back to those
times and I love competing I love
winning games I love going to different
Arenas and beating their team for their
own fans it's just the most funnest
thing that you could do but I have no
regrets I'm very happy and it's it's
been an absolute pleasure uh before we
move on to our locals and web our
patrons get to ask you questions we
always finish the interview with the
same question which is what's the one
thing we're not talking about as a
society that we really should be
I think the one word that I just wish
that I can just somehow magically uh put
in everyone's hardest empathy you know
once you have empathy
and then you can understand what others
are going through uh you know we can
just live an amazing life in in this
side of the world but on the other side
of the world people are literally you
know run away from Wars and running away
from bombs and run away from these
terrorist groups say they don't recruit
them you know
um once you have empathy you're going to
be able to try to understand the other
side and do whatever you can to help
them even if it means sacrificing
everything I think we definitely need to
talk about that word more empathy and
it's Freeman thank you for coming on the
show uh join us on locals where we ask
your questions tennis here over there
take care and see you soon guys
do you think turkey will ever be a
democratic country
[Music]